Welcome to our psychology 11 A.M session
uh and the next talk will be okay let's
see how it is
locations of multi-calibration Hardcore
sets dense models and pseudo entropies
very much for the introduction I'm
Sylvia and today I'll be talking about
complexity theoretic implications of
multicolibration and this has been
joined work with Cynthia at work and to
live with them
so everyone here knows what the
calibration is about but just to recap
proposed in 2018 by ever Johnson Kim
heinold and bathroom and the informal
idea is that we have a collection of
subpopulations that uh we think of them
as minority groups and a
multi-calibrated predictor ensures
calibrated predictions for all of these
groups simultaneously
unless everyone here knows it's been a
very fruitful notion in recent years
that's why we're here both in the
Practical side such works on improving
accuracy in randomized control trials
and also in connections to theater
connections to other fields of computer
science such as the work on family
predictors
um
in this talk I will focus on the
connections of multi calibration to
complexity Theory and kind of the
starting point will be very similar to
what Rachel talked about uh last talk
which is through the regularity Lemma
so before I explain
um the theorems that we're playing just
a summary of where we're going
um again similar to the setup that
Rachel started with we view multi
calibration as a strengthening of the
so-called regularity Lemma which is a
result that was shown by travisan to
siani and badan in 2009
and through that process we obtain
stronger and more General versions of
some fundamental theorems such as
impagliazzo Harcourt Lemma computational
characterizations of pseudo entropy and
the dense model theorem
in this talk I will only discuss the
Impala result because I only have half
an hour
um but you can read our work for more
details and just to give us a very quick
summary
studies hardness of functions and that
we will see in detail what the theorem
is about
um the second bullet point uh is
ethereum by vedan and zeng from 2013
that characterizes um
hardness of sampling with computational
entropy the notion of pseudo entropy and
lastly the dense model theorem which is
a result in additive combinatorics which
became famous because it was partly
because it was used in Greenland Towers
result that there exists arbitrarily
long arithmetic progressions of frames
because the punch line is that
multi-calibration allows us to obtain
generalizations of these theorems and so
that's important because it provides
insights in both directions right so
insights into what multi calibration is
doing from a complexity Theory point of
view but also
New Perspective on these classical
results uh in particular because we will
be kind of removing some of the weekly
hardness assumptions that we'll see in a
sec
okay so just to recap the notation that
I will be using so X denotes the finite
domain F denotes a class of in this case
will be Boolean functions and in the
fairness setting we think of X as
individuals and as f as membership
indicator functions to protect the
groups
G will represent the arbitrarily complex
function that we're trying to
approximate and H corresponds to the
predictor and then we say that H is will
be accurate if for every little F in the
collection ever functions this condition
is satisfied and again we have seen that
by just to recap what this is saying is
that within a protected Group H cannot
be inducing biases so the expected value
of G and H are Epsilon close
so but the accuracy is a definition so
the question is can we build such a
predictor that satisfies this definition
and that was answered in the positive in
the Chinese literature
um and so we can build such an object
that has low complexity and I will
address that in a second but um as
Rachel mentioned you know the punch line
is that this the multiocracy theorem we
can say is exactly the same thing as a
regularity Lemma of travisantuliani and
badan that precedes the literature and
organic fairness and in particular I
want to emphasize that the notion of
multiocracy is exactly
indistinguishable indistinguishability
with respect to a class of functions f
and um now I will say more about the
second point so before there was a
question of what does low complexity
mean so it's not low complexity itself
it's low complexity with respect to the
class F so that means that H can be
implemented with a circuit with Oracle
gates to functions in F and we only need
o of one divided by Epsilon squared such
Oracle Gates and then we can put things
together in a small circuit and so in
the complexity
settings where usually F corresponds to
Boolean circuits of polynomial size in
the length of the input what this is
saying is that then H can also be
implemented by a polynomial size
um when Epsilon is polynomialism
and so that's why I draw it in the
circles meaning H is not too much more
complex than the functions in F which is
what low complexity means again it's
relative to f
um and so in the talk I will be using
the notation H belongs to F of s which
means the class of functions with
complexity at most s with respect to F
and so in that case by the multiocracy
theorem slash regularity Lemma as is of
one divided by Epsilon square and as far
sheet said you can think of it as kind
of age is a linear combination of that
many number of functions in F
um as Rachel also introduced the other
kind of main point is that the regular
dilemma
ttb stands for traveling but then has
many important implications so as
Rachel explained there's a graph here at
the implication of fried chicken and
regularity Lemma which is a weakening of
the spread irregularity Lemma
um
the pseudo entropy result Dimension
Dental theorem and also uh the
cryptographic implications of the liquid
simulation Lemma and there's also
actually relationships to distribution
of zero knowledge
um and the question which is the same
setup that Rachel start with is
what happens if we use a stronger
multicolibration theorem instead and
what do these theorems become
and as you saw in the previous talk this
question has been studied by dorkly Lynn
and tankala for the case of uh the fried
chicken and the cryptographic settings
and in this work I'll focus on the
complexity theoretic implications and in
particular
um I'll focus on uh impactly at the
heart problem
and just to put the setup in diagram so
um the left
yes
personal implications in the future
yes so yes that's a good one so um on
the original paper of stands for example
um they show that so they prove they
were like dilemma and they showed that
you can use a regular Dilemma to prove
in pagliadosma the den small theorem and
the fritz cannot regulate dilemma all of
which preceded this paper uh but then
afterwards uh so without anything
proposes theorem and then they discuss
how in pagliama also can prove that
theorem and uh similarly for the
cryptographic results they published it
after the regular dilemma and they
showed that you can prove their theorems
using the regulator so by implication I
mean you can prove the theorem yeah
I did know yeah yeah okay it might be
wrong yeah okay thank you
right to the left hand side represents
fairness work and the Green Arrow is the
main implications I mean like lifting to
a stronger version uh so the
argumentation is trying to think of
something accuracy then the accuracy is
exactly the same thing as
the accuracy theorem is the same thing
as a regular dilemma and the regular
dilemma has these various implications
this stands for impaglia dough acrolema
and these two Dental theorem and this is
the entropy result that I won't get into
but uh this is what this refers to and
so the question is if we go through this
path what do this uh kind of lifted
versions of these theorems
become
okay so now I define multi calibration
formally uh just again just to put the
notation out there so we have x f g dsp4
um and now what we we're adding we're
adding the conditioning on uh h of X
being b b
um and again everyone knows here
everyone knows this but uh so the point
is that we're restricting the event to
the case where X belongs to a particular
level set of age and by levels that I
mean all the points in the domain that
get the same prediction by H
um and so when we look at all the
individuals who in the group who get
prediction V their actual expectation is
B and so it's calibrated
um so the notion is
was first presented uh with with
predictors but um for our purposes
notice that the level sets of the
predictoria induce a partition of the
domain
um right because you take your petition
into the values that it's assigning and
then you get uh these different parts
and so as it's done in the work on uh
Omni predictors we can work directly
with partitions and again the idea is
that a multi-calibrated partition is
Satisfied by the partition induced by a
multicolorated predictor when we take
the level sets
um and so what kind of the definition
becomes when we do that is that
when we condition an event that X
belongs to a particular PC which you
think of the level set of age then G is
Epsilon distinguishable from VP where VP
is the expected value of G on that piece
I write BP because before you can change
this H for V right because we're
conditioning on the event that age of x
equals V and kind of then the best you
can do because you're trying to get
close to the expected value of G is
actually predict that value uh and so
basically when we look at the
multicolorated partition if you still
want to think of the of the predictor
you should be thinking it of age is
returning the expected value of G on
that piece
and technically that I won't get into
but as Rachel mentioned there's the
issue of the level sets are too small so
whenever I say for all pieces I mean for
all large enough pieces
um and so again that's the definition so
the questions can we achieve such a
thing
and so this is the multi-calibration
theorem
kind of modified to this setting
so it's saying that we can always find a
low complexity partition that is
multi-calibrated and here by low
complexity I mean that it can be made to
have not too many parts in particular of
one divided by Epsilon Parts again this
is correspond to of one divided by
Epsilon level sets that uh within the
literature
um and also
um we have an efficient function and
again efficient means with respect to
the class F that tells you for every X
in which piece it falls into so that is
officially computable
okay so that was a recap on the fairness
Notions and now we go you know 20 years
back to 1995 where wrestling pagley at
the show in pagliazzo harlemma
um so it was shown in 1995 and then 10
years later the density was made optimal
from Delta to to Delta by hollandstein
um
so here's a formal statement and I will
now parse it slowly
so we're given a Boolean function G and
there's some an assumption on G so the
assumption is that g is Delta heart on X
with respect to the class F of s and
remember that F of s means all the
functions that have complexity and most
s with respect to the class F in this
case s happens to be fully of uh one
divided by Epsilon 1 divided by Delta
um and
I will also be referring to this as
Delta weekly heart to emphasize that
this is a weaker
notion of partners that what's about to
come
um so what does Delta weekly heart mean
and
let's look at it pictorially so it means
that for every function in this
collection every function in this
collection
when we so we take F1 from fs and then
we see where if one and G disagree you
can always find at least a Delta
fraction of the domain where the two
functions disagree
for every f
um so you take F1 and there's a Delta
fraction then you take another F2 and
there's another at least Delta fraction
um and this Delta fraction depends on
the F it's not fixed so it's moving as
we pick different functions in F
and that's the Assumption on G that's
what it means for G to be Delta weekly
hard
so the question is you know there's two
ways in which this could be happening
could be that
this kind of assuming hardness is spread
around on average in the domain or it
could be that it's concentrated on a
part of the domain at one and what
impact we had to show it is that the
latter is what's always true so if this
holds then you can always find uh what's
called a hardware set
um inside which for every f
and G do not agree with probability more
than a half plus Epsilon which is the
same thing as writing it as one half
minus Epsilon because then you
subtracting from one and in the talk I
will also refer to this condition as
strongly hard because it conveys that we
went from
weak harness to strong hardness
um the other important point is that
this age is fixed for all F's so it's
not moving around this is the same age
for every function in F and now we went
back to the kind of slightly smaller
class F not FS
um and so
the other important point about the
hardware set is that
kind of this is maximal hardness in the
sense that for any Boolean function if
you do random guessing then you're going
to guess with probability uh one half
um and so you can think of saying that
inside of the hardware set the function
G is maximally unpredictable
the other thing that showed about it is
its density so this wouldn't be as
interesting without a lower bound on the
density of the hardware set
um so
um hollenstein showed later that the
density is of this set it occupies at
least a two Delta fraction of the space
and this is important that it went from
Delta to Delta because to Delta is
optimal so in particular if you are with
probability of half in a set of density
two Delta then this implies the Delta
weakness assumption that we're assuming
on G
okay so two things on the hardcore set
inside it each inside the set G is
maximally unpredictable and it has
optimal density
and another remark on impact is that
usually
it's shown with distribution so I put a
set because that's more visually it
makes more sense visually but usually
it's shown for a distribution and so
that requires showing that there exists
a distribution such that h on X such
that when you sample according to that
distribution
um f and g don't agree with probability
more than a half plus Epsilon and then
you have to Define what the you know
analogous term for density is for
distribution but you can also show that
it's two Delta dense and so in pagliazzo
also showed a kind of a general
conversion from a distribution to a set
which is kind of a probabilistic
construction basically the idea is that
if you have a distribution that
satisfies this then for every X you flip
a coin with bias the probability Mass
that's given by H and if it lands heads
uh or like you add it to your set and so
you can show that because you're
assuming that this has enough density
then on average your set an expectation
you're set will also have two Delta
elements
okay so that was shown in 1995 2005 and
then in the result of uh Travis and Al
of 3009 they show the regular dilemma
implies
uh the hardware Lima and again recall
that we're assuming that g is Delta
heart how the how the proof roughly goes
is that
you apply the regularity Lemma to get
what we would Now call a multi-accurate
predictor h
then you use this H to define a
distribution and the intuition on this
distribution is that you put more mass
where G and H is agree
and then you show that this is a
hardcore distribution and that um
it has enough density and an important
point is that in that paper they only
get density Delta which is sub-optimal
because as I said two Delta is the
optimal density
so this is a rough sketch of the proof
so now let's go back to our research
question which is what happens when we
start with the multicultivation theorem
um and the idea is to you know see how
this what changes in this in this
pipeline
so the first important point about kind
of the hardcore version that we get is
that it holds for an arbitrary function
G
so you're no longer assuming that g is
not the weekly heart which is I would
say one of the main points because
you're kind of getting hardness out of
an arbitrary function
um we apply the multi-calibration
theorem
the one that you can get the low
complexity partition that's
multi-calibrated
um to get a predictor H or you can go
directly with the partition
um and then for every piece
of the of the domain you define a
distribution within that piece
and remember that BP is expected value
of G on that piece and then we show that
each distribution is strongly hard so
think of there's some sets that means
that in every part you can find
a little harder said where G is
maximally unpredictable for in every one
of this purple Little Hardware sets and
also you you know you also need a lower
bound on the density so we also show
that every again using the set notation
every one of these Hardware sets has
density at least uh 2bp where BP is a
minimum of uh VP and one minus VP so
basically uh EVP was below one half or
equal to one half it stays the same
otherwise it's subtract it from one and
so BP is between zero and one half
and we call that the balance of G on P
because notice that it's measuring kind
of how close you are to zero one right
so if it's a piece where G is very
unbalanced meaning it's it's very close
to the extreme zero one
then this is a kind of less interesting
lower bound right because the lower
bound is smaller could be it could be
even zero right and on a piece where G
is more balanced meaning its expected
value is closer to one half then this is
when the uh is a more interesting lower
bound but the point is this lower bound
holds for every piece
um also notice that
you know it makes sense that the lower
bound depends on G because this is for
an arbitrary G right so G could be the
constant zero function in which case
there's no way we would find hardware
sets uh and so in that case BP is zero
and so the end the hardware set is empty
but again so this characterizes the
little hacker sets for General G and
then the lower bound uh depends on on
that parameter
the other important interest yes
I'm understanding so like what you could
do is for each piece
give the most likely answer
and the two Delta would be the error of
that particular predictor and that's
what you're getting as far as the total
not only total but like uh each piece is
proportional to the error of that
predictor within that okay
exactly so VP is is the uh L1 error of
the optimal prediction
yeah
and so we'll also this kind of hinza is
that
why is the generalization of paracola
first of all these are we trying I'm at
this point uh and the hardware side is
going to happening locally on every
level set but also
um
you can glue them together
and actually before I do that I have the
formula statement uh so I have mentioned
this but again what the theorem would
say is that you give your set of Boolean
functions your domain so on and you can
find a low complexity partition so
remember we don't we have it most oh one
divided by Epsilon Parts such that uh
within each part there's a hardware set
for G and the parameter BP is what's
regulating the interestingness of of
what's going on there
but as I was saying um
the other reason why the generalization
is that we can recover the original
Hardware Lemma from this version because
we didn't use it to prove it right we
use the multicultivation theorem
um and so
if we bring back the assumption that g
is felt a weekly heart then you can show
that on average
the balance of G is at least Delta
and that makes sense because if it was
not at least Delta then you could take
your function f to be constant the
constant function on each piece where
it's the most likely value of G and then
you would be contradicting the Delta
weekly hardness right by using the
constant zero the constant one function
on every level set
um so then we show that if you glue them
together you have to take into account
the distribution then you get a hardware
set that has density at least two Delta
which corresponds exactly to the
foreign and another interesting point
about the comparison between what's
going on TTV and what's going on here is
that in ttb they get Delta not to Delta
and so multi calibration is also
recovering the optimal density parameter
when the accuracy was not
and another remark is that in the paper
by Wrangle pravidson from 2008. they
give a partition-based formulation of
the hardcore Lemma
um but they still assume that g is all
the weekly heart and the partition has
exponentially many level sets whereas
this one has polynomial image
okay and to finish I will give some more
intuition so I mean a natural question
is how is this possible given that g is
arbitrary and so I want to give what I
think is an interesting way of thinking
about multicultivation
um which is in terms of these kind of
like classicals to the randomness and
predictability equivalents by
created by Yao so a thing you can prove
is that if G is indistinguishable from
the constant one half function this is
equivalent to saying that g is strongly
hard or one half minus Epsilon heart and
we like this because this is exactly the
conclusion of the hardcore Lemma
wait
so given this principle let's go back to
the definition to multi-accuracy multi
calibration and like you can look at how
they differ
it's not just that the main is changing
right it's not just we're changing from
X to the piece another crucial
difference is difference is that H has
become constant by definition of a level
set right so this is a constant uh okay
it's the expected value of G but it's a
constant in zero one and so what this is
saying is that each piece G is
indistinguishable from the constant VP
and so you can think of a multicolorator
partition as saying that
it's giving you a partition of the
domain such that g is in distinguishable
proper Bernoulli of parameter VP on each
piece so G is behaving like a coin flip
with that bias on every piece
and then what I think is a nice way of
thinking about this is that you can
generalize this fact to any value in
zero one right this is about one half
but kind of more generally you can say
that if G has
um this expected value V all these
things are equivalent so if G is
indistinguishable from the constant
function V then you can also think about
it in terms of a Bernoulli or RVP but
also this is equivalent saying that g is
B minus Epsilon heart and this is
maximal hardness given that g has
expected value B right because the best
you could guess the majority element and
you would be right uh an average b b and
this is saying this is the best you can
do
um and the fourth point is that then you
can find the distribution of density 2B
where G when sampled according to the
distribution is strongly hard
so all these things are equivalent and
it's a useful thing of thinking about
the multicoloration partition but also
from one and four this gives us yet
another proof of our version of the
hardcore Lemma
which the idea is to use the
distribution HP to balance the expected
value of G from one from VP to one half
right so we want to have because this
corresponds to this equivalent right so
the idea is that when we sample
uniformly G has expected value VP
and then we can kind of give more
probability Mass to the minority
elements as to shift the expected value
of G to one half when sampled according
to HP and now we have recovered the Yao
principle and now we have strong harness
uh and so that is another way of proving
our original Power dilemma that doesn't
use kind of the proof of uh trebizan at
all
so hopefully that gives some intuition
on what's going on and why this is a
sensible result
um and so we'll conclude with the key
takeaways uh so I've only explained the
case but as I mentioned we obtain kind
of similar generalizations of the
decimal theorem and of the pseudoentropy
theorem by badan and zeng
um and you can read our work for that
um and kind of the punch line is that we
have improved these theorems using the
recent tools from fairness and it gives
insights in both directions into what is
the multi calibration partition doing in
terms of complexity and also new
insights into all complexity results in
the sense that we can start with an
arbitrary function and still try to get
hardness in some sense and so that
establishes new connections between
complexity and fairness and I think
that's very interesting because I think
as we develop a new field I think all
all good science finds connections to
older fields and so I think that's worth
exploring
thank you a lot for your attention
[Applause]
so uh we have time for a question third
one
there's um so Holland scenes proof that
gets optimal dependent
optimal size
I guess I'm just curious does it
does this proof looks considered like
the proof of utilization is it given you
kind of a group or how do they look
yeah it's very different because in our
case we're using kind of a sketch by TT
that there is
and so
the fact that we go from Delta to two
Delta it's really coming from the fact
that age is concept
um so that's kind of the key
element that enables that
um and Halton was doing something very
different than also using the mean Max
theorem in his group
is very very different in which creates
this uh distribution shifts into
integration in a very smart way
but it's completely yes
um I'm gonna disagree a little bit
because there are different ways he so
first Holstein has two proofs in this
paper
and one of those groups is one of the
proofs is using min max
um in the other proof is a is a boosting
algorithm
and uh I'm not
yeah I don't think you get this directly
from old scene algorithm
but it's not so different either
I think they're the styles
I think there's a I think there's a way
of tying everything together I don't
think
I think it's different ways of viewing
things rather than
[Music]
um
so for me what's new here at what's
Sylvia stuff really crystallizes is that
what is what was not in the posting
literature Services here now is this
notion of characteristics
never said
there's a lot of power and simplicity in
saying this and music
thanks again
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
okay so the next talk in the 11 A.M
session will be uh by uh on
indistinguishable generative models of
huge objects in both directions